senator cringe cory booker put together
perhaps one of the one of the cringiest
videos uh ever produced by a politician
and i thought that we would just watch
it together here it is
[Music]
running after each other and tackling
each other really bad acting on display
here
guys reporters are calling you're
tackling each other in the capitol we've
been through this before you have to
stop tackling each other all right
then we'll just tackle big consolidation
well a big egg consolidation is killing
rural america we need to get to work and
help the cow calf guys and the feeders
and the consumers taking it at the meat
counter too
that's why we introduced a couple bills
booker we need to get these bills done
we're going to get them done man i
appreciate you you're a good guy
okay oh my gosh
it was worse than i thought
all right we can stop that you turn that
off
you know you can tell a lot about
somebody from their sense of humor i
think uh because humor is one of the
most uniquely human things right and uh
i think humor is also a really good test
of iq
i think you don't even need all the
complicated iq tests
you could just uh someone just list for
me what you think the five funniest
movies of all time are something and i
could already i could get you i can i
can peg your iq
within a five point range just based on
that alone
and so what does that tell us about cory
booker let me keep that in mind
well that he's very stupid and he's also
barely human
although i did appreciate this so uh
cory booker's fans who he has fans
uh they loved this video they thought it
was very hilarious and there was this
one tweet from someone who said this is
the funniest video you'll ever see about
anti-trust legislation in the food and
agriculture industries
and you know what
she's right i mean i'll give i'll give
him that at least it is definitely the
funniest video i've ever seen about
antitrust legislation in the food and
agriculture industry so
got to hand it to him at least for that
well if you enjoyed that video be sure
to hit the subscribe button and ring the
bell to get more content like it if
you're craving more content go watch or
listen to my full show at dailywire.com
spotify or wherever you get your podcast